what's up guys I'm on a break from the
Ramsey Show Happy New Year to you all
hope it's going great so far I know a
lot of you have some big financial goals
you're hoping to hit in 20124 but here's
the sad data on this only 9% of people
who make those goals actually achieve
them and I want you to be part of that
9% and it's why we're doing this break
the cycle live stream on January 11th at
700 p.m. central Time 8:00 p.m. eastern
time it's completely free and we're
going to walk you through how to break
free from the debt cycle the stress
cycle and actually hit your money goals
and get guess what 10 people who
register will win $11,000 so I want that
to be you and I want you to hit your
financial goals so join us for this live
stream